hey kids as you know I am one of the
producers on your movie good boys and
unfortunately I'm here with bad nose you
guys cannot watch the trailer for your
own movie what it's just too messed up
for kids your age there's drugs there's
violence they're swearing and although
we've decided it's okay for you to do
these things in the movie
you can't watch yourselves do them in
the trailer a [ __ ] up oh it is [ __ ]
up you can say that you can't watch
yourself say that that's [ __ ] up
welcome to Hollywood I found all these
weapons in my parents closet I think
your parents flung a rose for Halloween
I'm knobby it's Japanese the nunchucks
mother oh okay I smell like [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm having a party tomorrow.you in ya
can throw a locust come they're my best
friends we did everything together just
so random two weeks in the 6th grade I'm
already a social piranha does this look
like a sippy cup no it's a [ __ ] juice
box
cuz I'm not a [ __ ] child you do not
want to go to Shawn's party not knowing
you have a kiss we could spy on my
neighbor she's a total nymphomaniac hey
stranger things go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ]
this is what happens when you don't
respect women I was begging my mom's my
best
but that's gonna kill me jump this is
how we get the drawing bag picture
there's mama burger - you took my bag oh
my god
there's Molly in there okay who's Molly
because she's not with us Jesus Christ
crap here's the plan
I'm gonna go to the party with a beer so
everyone knows that I'm cool what do you
have your pants
my penis pull it out when you see real
people kissing
I have an idea
[Music]
well what do you even kissed well not on
the mouth at least
[Music]